well we've got a brand new concept in
healthcare this is interesting doctors
are now prescribing the great outdoors
and science has proven that nature makes
us feel better and now the good news
network reports doctors in canada are
actually prescribing national parks
passes to their patients they say go
outside if you want to feel better
and the past actually gives them
unlimited access all year long and it's
an idea that started right here in the
united states and in canada the standard
recommendation will start at two hours
in nature per week okay and i know
you're an outdoorsy kind of girl right
i'm fascinated by this it kind of
speaks to the you know college course
like maybe we are looking for some
alternatives to live better lives
but i do picture you i know that you've
gone camping and you like that i don't
really do outdoors i mean my like nature
hike is like a two for one happy hour on
the patio that's like as
hardcore as it gets i'm like bro it's
cold but do you you like getting in
there right i do i do i'm a real cali
nature crunchy old gal here yeah i like
that about you i'm a tree hugging you
know cliche
absolutely when's the last time you like
went camping or slap slept outdoors or
something like that i i'm not a huge
camper i'm an rver oh yeah yeah um we're
going rving together in texas yeah it's
happening drew and i'm already planning
the road trip snacks i have a whole i
mean i am ready for this drew i want
making a playlist all of it yeah and we
have to stop at like gas stations and
get all the beef jerky and then yeah
and do you know what my favorite road
trip snack is do you know you probably
don't know out of all the chips in the
entire world
a funyun
a funyun
is
hello fun is right there in the name
hello and it's an underrated chip if you
had a funyun you guys the onion ring
flavored ones yeah and they'll stay with
you the rest of the day too
well speaking of food and things you can
ingest i'm very excited for our next
story because you might have heard of
oat milk
almond milk sure even the coconut
but guess what kids there's a new milk
in town and it's food news wow
a new
cut milk that the hottest new dairy-free
milk is get ready drumroll i had not
heard about this me either potato milk
what yes it turns out you can squeeze a
spud until some milk comes out
[Laughter]
everyone in europe apparently and they
love this stuff and it is coming to the
united states so we had some shipped
from
wonderful england and here are the stats
because of course i was like
the potatoes never done my body any
services right
we broke up a while ago potatoes and i i
i oh that humble potato
okay so here's the stats low in sugar
low in fat free of lactose soy gluten
and nuts super earth friendly in fact it
uses half as much land as oat milk does
and 56 times less water than almond
[Music]
okay uh are we gonna okay all right
cheers cheers
all right i love you too here's potato
milk okay
amazing
uh oh he doesn't like it rossi doesn't
likey
it's a milk that says i yam what i yam
i love it
i totally love it you really like that i
love it this is exactly what i'm looking
for in my life you know
less water and less carbon footprint if
you're going to go all in let's make it
count i'm so in do you like what part do
you like about it how it doesn't taste
good or doesn't smell good
wait i haven't smelled it yet
it's just none of it it's like i don't
like it oh i love it sure you can have
mine thank you that's what friends are
for
potato milk forever and by the way i
hope they don't package it in plastic
okay
do we know if it comes in plastic
packaging because that's another
important thing
here's hoping
[Music]
you